well four years ago las vegas didn't
have an nhl franchise
now they have the odds-on favorite to
win the stanley cup
sports director chris matthews joins us
more on a run that nobody could have
predicted chris oh it's crazy chris when
you think about that remember
that first year before the season
started sportsbooks had the knights at
500-1 to win the stanley cup
and vgk kept beating the odds sportsbook
directors were kind of sweating bullets
as the knights won the division the
western conference made it to the
ultimate series
the stanley cup final now after only
three years of existence the vegas
golden knights are the odds-on favorite
to win the cup
over at the superbook at westgate they
have the knights as a team to beat this
year at six to one then the lightning at
seven to one the avalanche eight to one
but it's amazing that vegas is putting
all the pieces together
to make a run at the cup and are the
favorites heading into year four
favorites because alex petrangelo is now
a golden knight
yeah so we opened up the nights at 7-1
to win the title
uh they made acquisition a player from
the blues
pete tarangelo and we moved them down to
6-1 now they're the main favorite for
the pool
they're already a solid team and then
that acquisition
just made their stock rise and you know
people being from las vegas people are
looking to
bet the knights so that number is also
based off of
anticipation of what bets are going to
come in all right hey if looking at just
the west and how the west is going to be
one vegas now the favorites at three to
one then colorado 7-2 dallas
st louis and vancouver are all 10 to 1.
you're